[Musique]
au premier coup d'oeil on reconnaît
l'arbre ses cernes qui nous indique son
âge
l'arbre c'est le sujet de prédilection
de valérie l'oiseau c'est à la fois un
personnage onirique et un végétal qui
qui a une variation assez
impressionnante face à fait maintenant
un peu plus de dix ans que je travaille
dessus et je n'ai pas terminé le sujet
autant en passant sur le détail de les
corses que par la branche que par les
feuillages que par toute la mythologie
que ça que sarah carl valeri l'oiseau
travaille depuis presque trente ans avec
un principal support le cuivre pour
révéler tout son potentiel
elle travaille à la pointe sèche et à
l'acide j'ai choisi le cuivre parce que
j'aime sa couleur la relation canton
lancre avec l'encré noire le le rapport
de thon rouge et noir
dans mes mots et puis c'est comme ça que
j'ai utilisé cette matière première pour
en concevoir des sculptures il ya
travaillant sur le thème du végétal donc
du coup j'ai amené le bois le papier qui
se surajoutent aux matériaux du métal
le bois et le papier de soie cette fois
est travaillée plié dans deux sculptures
une manière d'accrocher la lumière très
particulière où on peut être à la fois
dans des opacités d'étranges penche donc
du coup il ya quelque chose de très
de très sensuelle et qui renvoie aussi à
la transparence du végétal parce que
c'est ça aussi qui me plaît beaucoup
c'est que quand le soleil traverse les
végétaux on a aussi cette opacité
transparence des arbres qui se
multiplient comme une forêt qui n'est
une invitation à une balade
[Musique]